bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire pour un best-of un
peu particulier de cette deuxième saison
en effet je demande régulièrement mes
invités ce qui caractérise notre époque
et c'est toujours en image qu ils me
répondaient bien ce sont leurs réponses
celle de cette année que vous allez voir
maintenant du moins jusqu'à la crise du
coc vide 19
voici donc la solitude en image un peu
sérieuse du style de ce début de xxième
siècle
[Musique]
à
on va commencer par la vôtre hélios
azoulay
voici alors pourquoi lui en fait c'est
le genre de question quand même qui
affole un peu l'intelligence de trouver
une image qui concentrerait toute une
époque où jacques toubon la wec in una
d'écrire et la révélera est en fait il
m'est tombé l'autre jour une espèce
d'éclaircies dans ma tête
à propos de la technologie je me suis
dit mais la technologie c'est l'homme
désamorcer alors j'ai commencé à penser
à la technologie une photo de la
technologie mais non ça marche pas c'est
trop cliché etc
je pensais à une photo très très mauvais
goût parce que je dis on vit dans une
époque très très mauvais goût et une
société d'excitation plus même que de
consommation maintenant et puis non et
puis impression arrivé je me suis donc
il faut proposer pas d'image à l'aller
white paintings de rosenberg un grand
monochrome blanc même si non c'est qu'un
peu cuits de parler de rosenberg fait
tout je pensais bah oui c'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est 1951 et puis après je
me suis bon le monochrome le carré noir
sur sur fond blanc de malevitch qui
craquèle comme la banquise et
l'attaquent
je suis tombé vraiment sur ma passion
que je n'explique toujours pas et que
j'ai depuis que que j'ai vu que j'ai
cinq ans il enfin meubles de ma mémoire
d'enfant j'ai toujours rêvé de
téléphoner au groenland
et quand je vois ce visage aussi
accueillant recouvert petit à petit de
neige comme au temps de silence
et ça je trouve ça absolument magnifique
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que
j'attends et je crois en plus que ça
pour être plus sérieux si le site sur le
sérieux est si sérieux que ça je crois
plus que ça que les inuits ont beaucoup
de choses à nous dire sur la manière
dont on devrait être capable d'écouter
leur blancheur et alors juste moche et
une bonne société heureux parce que
généralement parmi toutes les images
qu'on me propose chaque jour dans cette
émission il ya plutôt de la neige qui
fond pour une fois il exactement
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
intimiste bac gains
moi j'ai choisi une image de d'un film
une fiction alors c'est un film de
terrence malick ça va sortir début
décembre
c'est d'après une histoire vraie s'est
inspiré d'un
d'un autrichien qui a été objecteurs de
conscience est un homme qui a dit non
qui a dit non il a dit non et claire il
a refusé de porter l'uniforme nazi et il
aurait pu s'en sortir
il aurait pu devenir infirmier on a
essayé là c'est bruno ganz avec lui dans
son dernier film ce qui vient de nous
quitter absolument c'est son dernier
film il aurait pu s'en sortir et
retrouver sa femme ses enfants mais il a
continué de dire non et en 2019 je
trouve que c'est un personnage
extraordinaire et puis d'une actualité
stupéfiante quoi ce qui se passe en
france en ce moment avec le gilet jaune
en iran a hong kong ou en amérique du
sud
c'est des gens qui se lèvent et qui
disent non et je trouve ça absolument
être en heure et en plus le film est
vraiment un chef-d'oeuvre quoi c'est
peut-être le plus beau film de terrence
malick est probablement un des grands
films de 2019 c'est une photo que j'ai
fait en bas de chez moi dans la rue
le combo en question est un artiste
graphique de rue enfin street artist il
a fait un mur je crois dans le 10e
arrondissement qui reprend un peu ce
thème là et j'ai choisi ça parce que le
le blasphème contre les icônes c'était
toujours de suggérer dans le cas de vol
chez watson dans le cas de haddock et
tintin de suggérer une relation
homosexuelle entre eux voilà hélas pour
la première fois je trouve que c'est une
image qui est extrêmement dessus avait
et tranquille qui affirme quelque chose
et je retiens rien de choquant entre ce
garçon ou pet et ce vieux loup de mer
qui s'embrassent et tout d'un coup ça
m'a fait comprendre qu'on était rentré
dans une autre époque où finalement
malgré les grincements les les interdits
les résistances bah voilà on allait
s'habituer à voir des gens des hommes en
train de s'embrasser tendrement il ya
quelque chose de très doux là dedans que
j'aime beaucoup voilà je connais pas ce
type là par les à shimon alegria ça
ressemble à un caravage c'est un
caravage salut savoir c'est un tabou qui
s'appelle le reniement de saint pierre
qui datent de 1610 et qui est conservé
au met
alors oui j'ai choisi une oeuvre qu'à
400 ans pour pour parler de notre époque
ben je pense que c'est la force d'un
chef-d'oeuvre ces deux
c'est de glisser sur le temps et d'être
toujours toujours actuel est toujours
contemporaine alors dans cette oeuvre si
on si on oublie que ça s'appelle le
reniement de saint pierre et que on sait
pas que c'est un récit biblique et qu'on
voit juste trois personnages on peut
dire que qu'on est tout de suite attrapé
par par un sentiment de menace qui pèse
un peu sur sur ses personnages donc il
ya un soldat une femme et un vieillard
et on sent qu'il ya une urgence qui est
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer est en fait tout et toute
l'action et est dit par les mains des
personnages il ya le soldat qui
s'apprête à pointer le vieillard mais il
ne pointe pas encore tout à fait donc là
c'est le couperet qui va qui va tomber
c'est très caravage adepte dans sa nasse
temps voilà c'est un moment très
particulier
pour lui mme ashton graphique en douce
avec le cadrage à mi corps comme ça
qu'ils rentrent dans la seine et et ont
saisi le le personnage il ya la femme
qui pointe déjà
et il ya le vieillard qui se pointe
lui-même qui se désigne lui-même et qui
a l'air de dire quoi moi non mais et
pour moi la force de ce tableau et la
puissance de caravage c'est que c'est
qu'en fait il nous met mal à l'aise nous
en tant que spectateur inouïe nous
déstabilise parce qu'il nous invite à
participer à une dénonciation un
jugement alors que
alors qu'on voit on voit pas la scène du
crime et on n'en sait rien il n'y a pas
de décors rien pour nous indiquer
exactement de quoi il est coupable et
donc il ya un peu ce côté de voyeurisme
avec cette femme qui est qui est jeté
dans la lumière et et ce devoir de juger
quelque chose d'enfantin dont on ne sait
rien ces traits de notre époque
voilà pour moi alors ça représente une
statue d'un sculpteur congolais qui
s'appelle freddy tsimba qui a pour
particularité de travailler dans toutes
ses oeuvres avec des objets qu'ils
récupèrent sur les champs de guerre de
son pays c'est des machettes c'est là en
l'occurrence des douilles c'est à dire
des objets qui ont tué et dont il fait
sous les balles des douilles des balles
et qui c'est monumental ce qui fait plus
de 4 mètres la statue est dans le palais
de chaillot
mais n'étant pas des grands escaliers de
chaillot et ça représente une femme sans
tête ça veut dire que ce n'est pas un
personnage particulier [ __ ] les femmes
en général où l'humanité en général
elle attend un bébé on ne va pas tout à
fait de la sur cette prise de vue et
tient dans la main un livre qui lui est
fait de clés qu'il a également récupéré
sur les fameux chiens de guerre qu'ils
parcourent yeux à l'intérieur du pays
alors c'est bien évidemment une oeuvre
extrêmement importante qui était
commandée par notre fonds de dotation de
manège de chaillot à l'occasion du 70e
anniversaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme qui a
été proclamée et signé à chaillot jean
donc c'est ça relie cette statue est
requis et la première entrée d'une
oeuvre contemporaine à dieu depuis 1937
depuis l'édification du palais tel qu'on
le connaît aujourd'hui et qui avait
totalement relié à vos ambitions de
l'époque qui affirme agissements une
vision humaniste qui voulez vous lutter
contre yom
cette tragédie qui allait se produire
les images d'un auto de la liste un
autodafé d'accueil à un autodafé qui
était votre roman dont on parlera tout à
l'heure tourne autour d'un auto neuve
sur le tour des des autodafés nazis
de mettre en tout 3 mais en même temps
si j'ai choisi une image d'autodafé pour
parler de l'époque contemporaine c'est
que hélas le plus jamais ça ne veut pas
dire grand-chose commencé puisque ont
été perpétrés il n'y a pas très
longtemps des autodafés en pologne qui
ont détruit des livres de harry potter
de twilight des masques africains des
objets cdpa julie mayer c'est tout ne
s'est pas c'est pas cet autodafé là et
puis plus récemment en turquie
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
livres d'opposants de erdogan ont été
brûlés
ce qui veut dire que 33 2019 même même
qu'on s'arrête sur les autodafés parce
que ça brûle oui parce que c'est
horrible on veut vivre interdite y
compris chez nous en france et aux
autres ça normal ou pas un film de
truffaut fahrenheit
oui mais kate est allée chercher fiction
oui ma faim à commencer par vous romain
pertes aulas
alors de quoi s'agit-il je suis un
habitué à plus de frédéric et à chaque
fois je me creuse la tête
alors là j'ai deux petites deux petites
choses ce que vous voyez là à côté de la
dame c'est une liseuse
je me suis toujours demandé c'est le
livre inversion maintenant quoi c'est
toujours un problème méric
à quoi ça servait parce que si vous
prenez ça c'est un petit objet qui si
vous avez plus de batterie ça ne
fonctionne pas si le fichier ne
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne pas et
ça ne trouve pas l'utilité en fait ça si
ça fonctionne c'est peut être utile oui
vous avez le même bruit font le bruit
fait schlick il faut fermer le même rôle
qu'un livre est donc je comprends pas
l'intérêt parce qu'en fait quand vous
prenez ça c'est parce que vous pouvez
pas chargés de livres mais vous le
prenez pour le train dans le train vous
allez quoi dire vous allez lire un livre
pour qu'on ne prenne pas un livre non
c'est si vous partez en moi qui par un
mois comme ça avec avec ça voilà c'était
mon petit truc est alors je me suis posé
la question est ce que mme berthe aux
échos lui disais que ça va pas durer
c'est vrai on arrive à la cuillère la
cuillère c'est quelque chose de
maintenance et quelque chose d'avant en
fait ce que vous venez de voir avant la
liseuse je pense que ça va pas durer
le livre est une invention parfaite
comme la cuillère est une invention
parfaite c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
trouvé mieux que ça pour manger la soupe
pour voir le café depuis des millénaires
et on parlera de vos lunettes après noël
pour voir le café on essaye maintenant
nous vendre une espèce de bâtonnet en
bois qui sert une apc mais on va revenir
en amérique un ouais donc à quand la
cuillère digital voici la question alors
là sont pas des kanaks mon cher à ckoi
sont des menottes
oui petite note c'est une robe de mariée
que j'ai fait
et que j'exposais à la maison de
l'amérique latine et un an un an et demi
c'est une robe fait avec 1500 petites
menottes et ça s'appelle l' hypothèse
posada parce qu'un espagnol exposé à
épouser épousé menottes
c'est le même nom et pour ce projet
j'avais invité plusieurs femmes de
différentes origines à participer à
rentrer dans la robe et dire ce que
c'était le mariage pour elle et j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses s'il y avait
des femmes dont il y avait des femmes
migrantes de réfugié politique des
femmes françaises aussi mexicaine mais
aussi des femmes qui étaient dans une
maison pour les femmes issues de
violence domestique et après j'ai fait
plein de visite avec toutes les femmes
et pour moi cette photo avec les femmes
à côté de la robe qui dise stop cette
violence ce top 7
elle dit stop parce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'elle car ici et
maintenant elle elle aussi mais elles
sont d or elles sont pas dedans d'accord
et pour moi cette image ça représente
aussi toutes les femmes qui sont dans
partout dans le monde maintenant dire
stop aux violences et les mains on dit
menottes et femmes mariées ça se dit la
même chose épouse et maintenant elle
même nom un espagnol c'était pas ça tu
exposes à s'écroule
c'est le fameux croche-patte l'a donc
pas très original
alors violences policières tout à fait
dérisoire par rapport aux florilèges que
nous offre la police depuis deux trois
quatre ans est d'ailleurs assez
intéressant que quand il était
interviewé sur chef du service public
récemment
edouard philippe c'est cette image de
violence politique a conduit à montrer
et pas les autres
oui mais parce que je pense qu'elle
paradoxalement alors qu'elle est
vraiment dérisoire encore une fois elle
dit beaucoup de chose de dur du reste et
notamment elle dit la charge affective
qui a dans la violence police et à c'est
à dire que la police a le monopole de la
violence légitime comme on dit et qu'est
ce que ça veut dire le monopole de la
violence légitime quand la loi est elle
même pas légitime
bon ça c'est des gens pour interroger
cette expression mais la police est
fondamentalement violente légitimement
ou pas bon là il ya un élément de
gratuité c'était à propos de toutes
violences policières un flic ou un
ministère de l'intérieur pourra toujours
dire qu'il ya une utilité à la violence
policière 10 pertes et malines des
manifestants parfois les taper un peu
brutalement pour les dissuader le côté
dissuasif de la force bon ça peut
toujours se ramener à une utilité ça pas
du tout c'est le geste de trop c'est le
geste surnuméraires c'est le sait le
zèle policier un peu ludique d'ailleurs
le croche patte ses cours de récré un
peu et là on voit quand même que les
policiers pourraient être les
dépositaires de l'ordre neutre
républicains pour autant n'en sont pas
des gens neutres
c'est dire que quand même ce qu'on dit
pas assez par delà les effets de
structure de la police
c'est que les policiers sont des
individus et qui sont constitués
idéologiquement or on sait très bien que
notre police française notamment je sais
pas si c'est le cas exactement dans
d'autres police ça serait intéressant
d'étudier
on sait que un nombre significatif de
free combo ont voté extrême droite un
aux dernières élections ont voté le
rassemblement national
on en est sûr vraiment à il ya beaucoup
de sondages qui vont dans ceux d'études
d'études n'ont pas de sondages qui vont
dans ce sens-là bon toute façon je pense
qu'une constitution majoritairement
droitière des flics français je verrai
je le dis sans sans même les incriminer
c'est un état de fait
alors c'est quand même intéressant de
voir que bonds à ceux qui sont des
gardiens de l'ordre républicain ne sont
pas neutres comme la république devrait
l'être ils sont tout à fait orienté de
logiquement dons qu'ils aiment bien
qu'assez du gauchiste il ya un plaisir
de casser du gauchisme assure 38 la
plupart des rangs des crs étaient
étaient occupés par d'anciens paysans
victimes de l'exode rural etc
qu'on accusait de prendre du plaisir à
taper sur les enfants de bourgeois de la
ville où ce qui est tout à fait possible
ce que disait pasolini entre les crs et
les étudiants du côté des crs a faim on
peut aller dans ce genre de paradoxe
intéressant mais là en l'occurrence je
pense que quand même c'est pas rien
d'avoir moi je me suis du coup je
m'interroge je pense qu'une question
qu'on peut ce ca dre c'est des gens de
gauche radicale par exemple qu'est ce
que ça voudrait dire une police de
gauche qu'est ce que c'est sachant que
dans tout corps collectif il ya toujours
la nécessité qu'il ya un ordre comme
quelque chose comme de la police pour
assurer la sécurité des uns et des
autres qu'est ce que ça pourrait vouloir
dire une police de go je le trouve que
c'est un sujet de dissertation hyper
intéressant quand on l'a pas vu sous la
gauche c'est ça aussi parce que non
surtout pas on avait autant de crimes
policiers non je trouve qui a changé
c'est quand tu dis gauche et enfin qui
tape un peu sur des gauchistes ne
croche-patte là il est vraiment sale
parce que si on voit après un poteau
j'envoyais maintenant cette somme prend
le poteau c'est méchant mais c'est
surtout moi je pense que c'est ça va
beaucoup plus loin que l'affrontement
casser du gossip cclat avec le mouvement
des gilet jaune et tout ça a été
vraiment pensé pour moi penser
politiquement pour pour casser le
mouvement pour pour dissuader pour faire
que des gens moi comme ma mère ils font
un début de manifestants après ils sont
bons pour faire qu'il y ait plus de vin
que ça enlève du monde quoiqu'ils
fragile voilà est fondamentalement ça a
quand même marché
il ya plein de gens bout d'un moment qui
sont dit bon je vais pas aller me
prendre une grenade
je vais pas aller me faire mutiler voilà
et je pense que ça va plus loin que
juste l'opposition traditionnelle
voilà flics contre blue est ce que je
voulais dire c'est que je pense que ce
flic fait du zèle par rapport à ça à lui
à cet effet de structure il ya un truc
qui m'a frappé de 20 20 secondes
c'était dans l'amp de premiers
entretiens que d'une banale à hautmont
de la faire je passe sur benalla gros
dossiers machin ville il ya un truc est
passé complètement inaperçu si les deux
lignes à un moment où ils caractérisait
les manifestants dont il avait frappé un
ou deux ils disaient que c'étaient des
dégénérés ou une phrase comme ça c'est
des dégénérés gauchistes ont rien dans
le cerveau soit ce jour-là benalla avait
quand même activer en lui une espèce
d'affect de haine par rapport à tout ce
qui est manifeste c'est pas par delà le
quai benalla lui même et ce qu'il
incarne par rapport au pouvoir
donc je pense qu'il ya quand même cette
constitution affective individuelle des
gens qui sont en charge de l'ordre qu'il
faut pas négliger
est-ce que j'ai peur de faire ralentir
les missions mais je voudrais rebondir
sa fonction débat sur la police
la police avait nommé en plus c'est une
plus une question qu autre chose mais la
police n'est ce pas justement une
création relativement récente il ya la
modernité et donc du coup une police de
gauche je sais pas si on peut même
penser qu'elle pouvait avoir
elle a pu exister en tant que tel ce que
ça à quoi ça renvoie j'imagine ce serait
plutôt ces cas là qu'est ce que serait
une chevalerie de gauche même si le
chevalier il ya peut-être une idée très
très old school mais pas forcément aussi
négative que l'idée de police qui n'est
franchement associé qu'à des actions que
toute âme honnête ne peut que réprouver
et pour répondre à la question qu'est ce
que ce serait une police de gauche et un
livre de sébastian roché que j'ai
souvent invité de cette émission et
d'autres avant et d'ailleurs qu'on
entend plus en plus sur les autres
chaînes parce que depuis qu'on dénonce
les violences policières
c'est un livre qui s'appelle de la
police en démocratie c'est un peu une
réponse est oui dit effectivement que
beaucoup de police dans d'autres pays
d'europe se sont réformés et pas
tellement en france et il explique
pourquoi c'est angela merkel oui devant
l'entrée d'auschwitz à choisir cana
parce que quand vous nous avez envoyé le
mail vendredi
j'étais très chatouillé par cette
expression 21e siècle je me disais mais
moi je ne sais pas de quel siècle je
suis mais je suis aussi du 20e et et
qu'est ce qui est important pour moi je
vraiment j'étais complètement perdu et
j'ai entendu aux infos le fait que
angela merkel y était et jardins fois
pour la première fois l et j et j'ai
entendu le journaliste de france info
qu'il disait une phrase du genre comme
s'il était étonné qu'elle soit émue elle
était ému c'était extraordinaire et je
me suis dit mais oui pour moi il ya une
seule chose qui compte dans ma vie dans
ma présence sur la terre un événement
c'est cet événement là ne pas l'oublier
peut-être parce que je suis né moins de
20 ans après la fin de la guerre donc je
vais très très proche de ça mais je
voudrais de le transmettre à mes enfants
c'est c'est la première
la première parole parce que politique
que j'ai dit à mes enfants quand ils ont
appris à parler que c'est que ça avait
existé et qu'il ne faut pas l'oublier et
que on a l'impression que évidemment ça
enfin pas évidemment ça s'oublie on a
évidemment l'impression qu'il ya des
gens qui l'oublient puisqu'il ya encore
des tags de croix gammées sur des tombes
juives c'est sam sam est totalement
insupportable et je voudrais que la
terre entière s est même conscience on
on a on peut pas avoir oublié ce qui
s'est passé on ne doit jamais l'oublier
et moi j'aime de la vie que quand on
reçoit un paquet on le transforme et on
l'envoie autrement le paquet qu'on a
reçues en ayant vécu ça parce qu'on l'a
tous vécu indirectement indirectement
tous nos nos parents nos grands parents
l'ont vécue d'une certaine manière
donc on reçoit ce paquet comment le
renvoi là le contraire de sa part la
paix par là par la bienveillance par
l'acceptation de l'autre par tout ce que
ça représente et de mal on peut le
transformer en bien
[ __ ] voilà mais ça ne semble pas aussi
facile que ça c'est qu'on en est loin
non c'est sûrement pas facile mais je
comprends pas comment ça peut être
différemment
elle est pas d'aujourd'hui à l'ehpad
aujourd'hui on voit bien la différence
justement on voit bien la différence il
n'y a pas de téléphone portable
il ya il ya une espèce de gros
magnétophone comme ça sur la table c'est
des flics quatre flics autour cinq flics
dont à droite charles pellegrini jeune
public et la petit petit petit fils d'à
l'oreillette est en réalité ils sont ils
sont en train d'écouter en direct des
voyous pour essayer de voir à quel
moment pascal et postes et laisser la
grande époque des flagrants délits donc
les voyous à l'époque on les laissait je
le rappelle c'est quand même partie
qu'ils ont les laisser faire leur hold
up et ont laissé au moins et on les
chope et à la sortie de les amener chez
le juge avec leur butin à la main
d'abord là ils ont fait ça s'appelait le
flagrant délit et les policiers en
police judiciaire ne visait que pour le
flagrant délit c'était leur grand rêve
on va dire donc là ils sont à l'écouté
pour voir à quel moment la bande va la
bande de voyous qui sont en train de
surveiller va se mettre en marche pour
être derrière ils sont derrière en
permanence en fait
alors on comprend tout de suite que
c'était un boulot à l'époque très
artisanal très manuel très finalement
très très humain comme ça ils sont et ce
sont eux les patrons c'est le
commissaire ans le commissaire en direct
qui écoute et qui sait de reconnaître la
voix parce qu'il faut aussi dire qu'à
l'époque les boyaux il les connaissait
coillot il ya 3 400 grands voyous
inscrits au fichier du grand banditisme
et les connaissait tous quasiment par
leur nom leur alias et peut-être même
par leur voix donc voilà on est au 127
rue du faubourg saint-honoré qui était
le on était là dans un bureau dans un
bureau de flics évidemment ces voix là
c'est assez vintage au niveau du bon
climat j'avoue c'est el haya nakamura
voilà à y avait à cabourg hadjadj à elle
est française elle est française
et faut-il le rappeler a les françaises
elle est aussi allée aussi banlieusards
d'années d'origine malienne
elle a du bagout elle est très critiquée
elles vont partout dans le monde
elle vend partout parce qu'elles
représenteraient linguistiquement la
perdition de la france alors que c'est
de l'artiste française je pense qu'
actuellement voir le plus à l'étranger
et c'est la nouvelle ambassadrice
il faut s'y faire bon on s'y fait très
bien pourquoi vous avez l'air de dire
qui s'en plaignent oui en a qui s'en
plaignent justement la façon de parler
la culture aussi un peu comment dire
pour le hard largo quelques mots de
langue africaine où quelques monde de
l'orgue caraïbes
ben voilà c'est moi je vais vous chanter
dans un défilé de mode pour la fashion
week tomberez peut dire exactement ce
qu'il y avait le monde entier dans la
fashion week à davos et genève et
j'adore cette petite et nikos aliagas
prononcent très bien son nom exactement
donc voilà il ya des ja ja ja il ya des
moments comme ça où on n'arrive pas à
prononcer son nom n'arriveront comprends
pas ce qu'elle est c'est à ya donc un
prénom malien nakamura japon il ya trop
de mélanger parfois on sait pas quoi en
faire
et moi j'adore j'adore cette petite je
vais choisi un sujet qui ont été
enregistrées chez nous d'ailleurs
oui mais pas dans ce contexte non non
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'est à
dire je me cherchais quelque chose sur
l'hystérisation de la société et
l'historisation du débat notamment en
france dans le monde aujourd'hui la
difficulté je crois enfin j'ai le
sentiment tout cas croissante à débattre
des sujets dits sensibles qui devrait
pas être sensible à supporter en fait
que les autres ne soient pas d'une a su
perdre avec les autres soient pas de
nombreux nationalistes me concerne c'est
bien dans son dernier livre et j'ai
cette photo est apparu que j'ai trouvé
absolument monstrueuse entre 7,7 cette
jeune fille cas pas l'air du tout de
mesurer le tragique de l'évêque blanc
l'événement derrière qui qui
symboliquement signe la fin de la
décristallisation dans le monde et en
même temps
c'est la conjonction entre les tentes
les tentes les deux événements dont on
ne sait pas lequel est la cause de
l'autre et si finalement la sortie n'est
pas une punition divine
d'un dieu qui en aurait eu marre
construit sa maison supermarché avait
choisi le même temps moi je trouve cette
photo extraordinaire parce que
l'attitude de cette jeune fille jette
aux fascinantes totalement détaché en
train de faire un clin d'oeil
parce qu'elle envoie un baiser faudrait
inviter beaucoup pour l'interviewer
passalacqua le pensait exactement
en faisant cette fille que qui se
trouvent très est assez mémorable je
pense effectivement
[Musique]
vivant panel on sait que vous connaissez
toutes les stars de la planète dont
c'était c'est tout c'est ce que j'avais
à dire
non pourquoi pas ce que c'est
c'est l'époque pour moi de sept filles 1
quand même assez abordable c'est rihanna
aussi de serrer hanaoui avec une amie et
je parle de cette quelques cheveux gris
et non c'est l'époque de cette fille
complètement abordable qui faisait une
opération de communication pour ses
fringues qui tout d'un coup tout chauds
vêtements de en levant je ne sais
combien c'est à la fois le pouvoir de la
star est-ce que jamais été aussi aussi
avec une telle possibilité de se
démultiplier et le côté abordable en
fait un super bien géré et très contrôlé
mais bon elle était là à cette soirée à
parler avec tout le monde
moi j'étais en train de me dire que
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça uniquement que
je voulais que ce passé cette photo est
en train de me dire que elle elle
adorait les cheveux blancs donc j'étais
enfin bon je suis fils elle est adorable
elle abordable pour une femme noire vous
qui est comme une grande influence dans
le monde de la mode aussi
oui mais ce n'est pas non non non non
non non ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
normalement on ne peut jamais approché
ces gens mais on peut pas là elle l
avait dit elle disait d'ailleurs laissé
les c en fait elle est tellement
puissante en fait et elle a tellement
montrer d'elle sur les réseaux sociaux
elle gère tellement en fait tout son
image que elle sait comment gérer si on
s'approche elle sait comment vous
envoyer promener vous dire que c'est
fini
elle n'a pas besoin d'eux il ya des
gardes du corps mais elle elle gère la
relation avec vous quoi et comme elle
gère la relation sur les réseaux sociaux
donc c'est l'époque alors c'est une
image qui en fait a resurgi récemment
parce que c'est une oeuvre de
jacqueville aigles est un artiste que
j'adore qu'un affichiste quelqu'un qui
arrachent les affiliés est plutôt plat
n'a fléchi c'est celui qui dépose ce qui
s'y dit celui qui les voilà qui lui pose
sur un support pour en faire une oeuvre
d'art alors 7
cette oeuvre elle date de la fin des
années 1980 mais est bien jacques guy
daigle et l'a proposé la montre et très
récemment et ça montre du coup tout
l'obsolescence de la publicité puisque
on est face à 36,15 code ni quitte à
jouer et il faut le rappeler pour ceux
qui n'étaient pas nés c'est les débuts
du minitel en fausser la fin c'était
déjà la fin du minitel est en fait je
trouve que c'est une image tout à fait
caractéristique de ce qu'est l'art
au logis de nos obsolescence programmée
c'est à dire que on a déjà le signe de
ce que sera internet on est déjà dans
quelque chose de complètement dépassé
puis c'est aussi le trouve une icône de
cette pornographie frelaté qui
caractérise beaucoup notre notre société
donc voilà oeuvre tout à fait
révélatrice de la de l'époque et des
changements d'époque souvenait que
jacqueville et glisser tout ça c'était
vraiment les affiches qu'ils avaient sur
le mur exactement qui est en plus des
affiches apposées sauvagement en fait et
puis qui ensuite étaient recouvertes par
la gtc secte dont il faisait une oeuvre
d'art on les en les transposant ensuite
dans les galeries ou musées c'est
l'image de tayac nicolas beau jake
hoffman qui vient de finir c'est un
petit clin d'oeil à l'antispécisme
puisque c'est une série où les
personnages sont tous avec des cordes
humain avec des têtes d'animaux ou du
maroc est une espèce de grand mélange
qui se fait est ce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est le dédoublement de personnalité en
fait que ça laisse entendre à savoir que
le le beau jake qui est bien habillé qui
à l'extérieur c'est un peu la version
idéale du vrai beau jake qui est
peut-être même en train de se noyer peut
qu'il est en train de nager qu'est ce
que vous a pas beau jake un beau jake
hoffman s'est donc c'est le personnage
est en fait ce que j'aime bien c'est
cette image là qui à mon avis est très
prégnante aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux qui est qu'en fait on a un mois
idéal qu'on projette et qui finit par
nos tyranniser qui est en permanence en
train de nous regarder
alors que nous on est peut-être on vaut
peut-être pas mieux que d'être sur la
chine
moi j'ai choisi un tycoon à un les
ticuna c'est un peuple qui vit dans la
région dite des trois frontières donc à
la au point où se touchent la colombie
le pérou et le brésil donc on est en
pleine amazonie
parce qu'il fait partie de notre époque
autant que les gilet jaune où les
salafistes ou ou l'iphone dissous enfin
tout ça ils partagent notre époque avec
nous et ce qui est intéressant aussi
avec cette image c'est qu'elle est posée
elle est composée je pense qu'on va
parler un petit peu de l'histoire de
l'art mais on a c'est pas un tycoon à
photographier chez lui c'est un tycoon à
la dans un contexte un petit peu noir
qui dégage le sujet comme aurait pu le
faire un peintre de la renaissance ou un
peintre
de l'âge d'or flamand c'est un
photographe brésilien qu'il l'a fait il
s'appelle diego john atta et je pense
qu'il a vu les peintres de la
renaissance et qu'il a vu les peintres
de l'âge d'or flamands qui eux mêmes ont
transmis des choses aux peintres
européens qui ont transmis voilà c'est
la circulation des images c'est aussi de
ça dont parle villes des musiques du
monde la circulation des cultures avec
ce petit kuna qui mangent à nos maris
c'est-à-dire un fruit local qui pousse
dans sa région d connaissent pas encore
apporté à ma connaissance ou peut-être
sous forme de jus il est connu dans un
des jus qu'on boit à un cocktail de fric
voilà droit d'entrée le fric nautique
mais je pense que nous
c'est à la salle à c'est une jeune
révolutionnaire soudanaise la photo est
date d'avril et elles s'étaient levés
sur cette voiture pour chanter jan chan
de révolution ça a fait le tour du monde
c'est devenu viral c'est ça a été très
rapide et du coup ça représente vraiment
notre monde d'aujourd'hui où
l'information va très vite et aussi on
voit tous ces gens avec leur téléphone
en afrique on est dans un dans un pays
qui dut on a du mal à sortir
l'information
et pourtant elle est sortie et cette
femme qui représente du coup tout pour
moi c'est la voix des femmes aujourd'hui
qui s'élèvent de plus en plus et
aujourd'hui on
on a de plus en plus la parole et voilà
pourquoi j'ai choisi cette photo qui est
un message aussi d'espoir de
et puis on voit aussi que le monde va
pas encore très bien mais il va souvent
mieux qu'on croit voilà alors pourquoi
celle-ci 11 novembre 2018
les hommes restent à l'elysée les femmes
on les amène à versailles et si j'avais
un sous-titré cette photo des conjoints
femmes mais aussi des hommes
effectivement je dirais que c'est un
petit peu le passé qui passe pas on
revient quand même un petit peu assez
logique ou une séparation g des sexes
des genres les hommes dans l'impression
qu'ils font les choses sérieuses à
l'elysée puis les femmes on va leur
montrer versailles et les amuser un
petit peu oui mais vous vous êtes vous
un peu puisqu'il y avait des femmes à
l'elysée celle qui était au pouvoir
et puis leur conjoint qu'on voit ici
pourquoi versailles avec les épouses
pourquoi les éloigner autant ah oui les
hommes de pouvoir ont toujours besoin du
conseil des femmes
oui on va le voir tout à l'heure quand
on parlera du corps de la reine devient
on dirait un montage non un peu aussi
surtout c'est bizarre on dirait une
fausse photo de disneyland
c'est quand il adapte 30 secondes à
terre touché mais en fait non pas
forcément
mais ils sont très très nombreux c'est à
quelle occasion le 11 novembre 2018 ah
oui donc où il ya tous les chefs d'états
et série qui était tellement et j'ai
trouvé que c'est une photo qui
représente encore une fois peut-être ce
rapport de force son corps traditionnel
certes ce ne sont pas des rois et des
reines mais tout de même
cette séparation j'ai trouvé que le fait
de j'allais dire un petit peu éloigné 1
les conjoints femmes mais aussi des
hommes à versailles il y avait un côté
bon ben il faut bien s'occuper des dames
on va les promener en valeur montré de
jolies choses et en plus on revient
quand même dans un des symboles de
l'ancien régime ou mocienne des symboles
de la fin de la première guerre mondiale
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais je pense que
c'était plus pour visiter les
collections avoir louis xiv que la
grande guerre c'est ni debout oui
effectivement notre époque regorge des
images terrifiantes
moi j'ai choisi le retour de la poésie
le dans l'espace public
le retour de regroupement de personnes
qui
se retrouvent au moment du coucher du
soleil pour rester tenir debout
c'est un mouvement qui est apparu à un
moment poste attentats faut se rappeler
un petit peu de l'état général du pays
d'ans à ce moment là l'apathie générale
et petit à petit des gens se sont mis à
être ensemble
pour moi c'est la suite sur la place de
la république à paris tu as fait c'est
la suite d'une série de contestations
contemporaine ce soit les révolutions
arabes ce qu'on appelait les émeutes de
banlieues tôt les révoltes pour moi de
banlieue est
et puis qui préfigure d'autres
révolutions à venir donc voilà j'avais
envie de parler elle est très ancienne
on dirait là elle est très ancien mais
pour moi pour moi c'est un pont
justement parce qu'on demandait une
photo de tir présent de l'époque et moi
c'était un pont justement entre deux
époques entre le 20e et 21e siècle un
personnage qui nous en tant que
photographe de presse en tant que
journaliste nous a vraiment intéressés
nous a passionné et puis il est interdit
d'interdire
lui non il y voit là il me dit tu veux
tu le photographier en train de fumer
des clopes en train de boire des coups
c'est vraiment il représente tout ce que
nous n'avons plus le droit de montrer
aujourd'hui à la télévision plus le
droit de dire et d'ailleurs c'est drôle
parce que dire j'étais sur ma mobylette
en train de fumer un cigare est un flic
qui m'arrêtent qui me dit on faisait pas
de fumée il est interdit d'interdire à
une grenade je pensais pas du tout à ton
émission n'est pas du tout je pense est
un slogan plus en plus beaucoup plus
anciens du siècle d'avant et le mec qui
n'a rien dit il comprenait pas sa
mobylette tu n'as pas battu mais enfin
tu n'as plus le droit de rien et chirac
me fais justement penser au dernier
homme politique qui s'autorisent est
tout ouïe et c'est une période qu'on a
malheureusement qu'on est entré qui est
en train de disparaître votre image
avoue michel pech thoreau
on n'est pas très noble elle dit pas mal
de choses sur le société contemporaine
d'abord à la tire l'attention sur le
problème des ordures qui va croissant
certaines régions du monde ça devient
dramatique
et puis sur la couleur verte qui est
chargé de sauver la planète en quelques
semaines
vers quelle vous avez consacré un livre
voilà c'est ma couleur préférée depuis
que je suis tout petit garçon mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus dire j'aime
le vert sans passer tout de suite pour
en soeur de l'environnement et c'est
tant mieux d'ailleurs
et puis elle nous dit aussi que la
couleur ça sert à classer c'est la
première fonction sociale dakhla s'est
classé par la couleur associée opposé
comme dans bureautique par exemple au
dossier no ce dossier par la couleur on
classe et là on a un classement un peu
déroutant limite grotesque que le bac
est vert mais il ya écrit bacs jaunes
ça montre qu'entre la couleur nommé la
couleur montré l'écart est assez grand
ce n'est pas neuf d'ailleurs dans les
sociétés anciennes on trouve déjà moi
j'ai des documents médiévaux où on a des
échantillons de tissus plus des termes
de couleurs en dessous ça s'emboîte pas
de la grèce
voilà et s'avance le poids des mots 1
en matière de couleurs comme dans
beaucoup d'autres choses le mot est plus
fort que la coloration que l'objet 4 est
ce que nous cherchons à dénoncer cette
cette image
cette photo a été prise par mario cruz
qui est un photographe portugais et
c'est une
c'est cette image c'est un fleuve
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est un fleuve c'est le fleuve pasig
pas de sig à manille aux philippines
le gamin qu'on voit est vivant il dort
sur un matelas qui entre guillemets
flotte sur ce fleuve et son job à ce
gamin pour survivre c'est de récupérer
des objets recyclables et il faut savoir
que le fleuve pasig est tellement pollué
qu'il a été déclarée biologiquement
morts dans les années 90 et il y à des
endroits où il y a tellement d'ordures
au tour et ce gamin que ce gamin peut se
déplacer parce que là l'image c'est une
photo que le gamma peut marcher sur les
eaux sûr sûr sûr les sur les ordures et
que sans avoir les pieds mouillés
tellement le fleuve est pollué et je
trouve que ça en dit long sur l'époque
d'aujourd'hui on parle énormément
d'écologie et lancé une image sordide et
ironique parce que son job pour pouvoir
survivre sa dreux récupérer des objets
recyclables intéressant votre réponse
ian jacobs
la voici qu'est ce que c'est ben moi ça
m'a beaucoup ému de voir cette photo
évidemment c c'est une galaxie pâtissons
de galaxies qui se rencontrent mais bon
on pense tout de suite à un embryon
foetus et on se dit voilà c'est de notre
époque de pouvoir aller si loin dans
l'univers envoyer des sondes
photographier l'infiniment en loin et en
même temps ça vient nous parler de nous
ça vient nous dire aussi on effets de
particules on les fait se sentir monde
là on voit la fille du professeur d'une
physicien on va en parler tout près
voilà exactement mais grosse manche et
j'ai joué une pièce de didier riboud
justement où il ya une chanson qui
s'appelle whiting de boone et
j'en sors de guilde copie exacte et au
moment où les hommes sont marché sur la
lune
voilà aussi on en voit le petit blanc
sur la lune et moi je paye pas mes
factures et j'arrive pas à payer
l'hôpital est donc de savoir que c'est
çà et là
blanchette je me dis mais en même temps
on a lié à une sonde qui vient dans
l'univers si loin trouver ces deux
galaxies qui se rencontrent et elle
vient nous dire ça parle aussi de nous
qu'on a failli quelque chose qui nous
ressemble et qui nous a bien quelque
chose de très de très tendre quand on me
balance et se ressemblent à un pénis au
repos
moi je viens coeur oui c'est vrai avec
le sang on cherche souvent notre
relation avec ce grand monde et voilà là
y'en a une qui nous est proposé et c'est
vrai que souvent les astronautes qui
quittent la terre et qui la voit de loin
disent qu'ils ressemblent beaucoup
d'amour ou de prêt tu vas être quelque
chose et je crois que ce sont des
messages aussi qu'il faut un pain qui
nous qui nous touche aussi quand on voit
des photos comme ça trappe et la beauté
de la vie enfin la beauté de ce que du
mystère de ce que nous sommes
de quoi s'agit-il alors il s'agit de la
première image d'un trou noir que
une équipe de la nasa a obtenu cet été
je crois et je les choisis ce que je
trouve qu'elle est assez représentative
des 20 ou 30 dernières années de nos
sociétés
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un trou noir
c'est une singularité dans laquelle
l'information est accélérée l'infini et
normalement rien ne peut en sortir et
j'ai trouvé que justement sur les 20 ou
30 dernières années où on entend tout le
temps parler d'accélération de
l'information des innovations de rupture
de toutes ces choses là
le fait qu'on ait enfin une image alors
évidemment on voit pas ce qu'il ya dans
le trou noir on voit ce qu'il ya autour
mais le fait qu'on ait une image c'est
peut-être le signe que dans nos sociétés
ça y est on est sortis de cette espèce
d'histoire absurde de l'accélération et
qu'on va prendre un peu le temps de voir
ce qui se passe pour comprendre comment
nos sociétés vont évoluer là qu'olivier
bidon donc c'est à la fois une image
très contemporaine en a malheureusement
l'habitude de voir ces images
d'embarcations notamment en méditerranée
qui qui font naufrage avec à leur bord
des réfugiés qu'ils viennent du
moyen-orient qui tiennent de d'afrique
c'est un drame c'est aussi de la part de
ceux qui se risquent dans cette aventure
parce que c'est une aventure que de
franchir la mer c'est aussi une bouffée
d'espoir s'ils franchissent la mer s'il
cherche à gagner nos pays beaucoup plus
riches que les leurs c'est parce que ils
ont l'espoir d'un monde meilleur
d'un autre monde ce qui nous oblige
aussi à prendre en conscience de sept de
ses difficultés
mais l'historien que je suis ne peut pas
non plus oublier que des drames comme
ceux ci et des vagues d'espoir on les a
connus de à toute époque depuis
l'antiquité jusqu'aux période plus
modernes rappelons nous que les
irlandais en 1848 partent vers les états
unis traversent l'atlantique poussé par
une famine qui fait des millions de
morts que ces naufrages sont
emblématiques et j'ai un peu travaillé
sur le naufrage de la méduse 1816 il va
devenir le symbole finalement de cette
double dimension l'humanité qui est
livrée à elle même conduit à s'entre
dévorer et en même temps cet espoir que
le peintre jéricho va signifier à
travers cet homme noir vu de dos qui
tend un mouchoir à la fois vers le
bateau qui vient les sauver peut être
aussi vers le ciel
au mois de novembre dernier j'ai emmené
ma fille en islande d'abord pour lui
montrer les dernières baleines et puis
montée le mans est jacky avait toujours
été recouverts de neige jusqu'à trois
ans depuis plus d'un millénaire et je
voulais l'emmener en norvège ou alors au
canada mais c'est de plus prendre
l'avion gaulle et l'obscurité pour moi
dans un instant et en fait ce qui est
terrible c'est chez les orks et qu'ils
ont une vie familiale quand il tombe
amoureux
ils font des champs quand ils font
l'amour ils font des chants toute la
communauté est heureuse quand ils
accouchent ils font des champs et très
récemment au canada il ya un groupe
d'orques qui a porté un enfant qui est
mort parce que les enfants de une durée
de vie de 3 à 4 semaines les enfants au
rck
voilà puis ce qu'ils mangent des
poissons qui sont contaminés par les
poissons d'élevage qui contaminent des
poissons sauvages et pendant trois
semaines c'est orques ont refusé que cet
enfant meurt et pendant trois semaines
il l'emportait à tour de rôle
et le jour où ils l'ont laissé descendre
dans les abîmes
ils ont chanté un chant qu' aucun
scientifique n'avait jamais entendu et
en fait c'était un champ d'extinction et
je pense que ça caractérise bien notre
époque où 18 mai nord
oui de garde de la chine oui voilà deux
cartes de la chine avant et après le
coronavirus après non mais pendant et
surtout avant et après
la mise en stand by de la production
économique les gens qui restent chez eux
et ben voilà on a la réponse à la crise
écologique à gauche donc la tache jaune
à l'état jaune
oui ce sont des images de la nasa et
apparemment ce sont les émissions de
dioxyde d azote
donc ils sont émises par la combustion
fossile et c est donc lors du
coronavirus avec la mise en quarantaine
des personnes on se rend compte qu'il ya
beaucoup de taches jaunes
voilà c'est merveilleux tout simplement
parce que les gens circulent mois
produisent moins exact les usines sont
fermées et cetera et cetera donc moins
de pollution comment donc voilà il n'y a
pas besoin de multiplier les coptes 21
il écope 22 et je ne souhaite pas de
virus mais on a quand même une idée de
la solution finalement la décroissance
alors on voit derrière le bouquet de
tulipes offert par jeff koons à la ville
de paris on y reviendra bien et le point
de départ de votre livre mais au premier
abord ça doit être la fashion week
alors c'est la fashion week s'est tiré
du hem le magazine le supplément du
monde la de samedi dernier c'est une
photo des photos de juergen teller qui
est allé faire poser les modèles de la
fashion week dans cet endroit qui est en
travaux
ce qui m'a intéressé si vous voulez
c'est que je crois que disait symbolique
de l'époque bond à des îlots de luxe au
milieu d'un pandémonium d'objets de
voitures de l'acd scooter un élire
derrière il doit y avoir un ennemi coup
quelque chose comme ça non serait plutôt
une sorte de fenwick
l'arbre est protégé bien sûr parce qu'il
faut jamais toucher à la nature il faut
absolument la protéger c'est bizarrement
protéger d'ailleurs paris bim urbain par
un mobilier urbain affreux c'est pas
pour parler du sujet de mon lit de mes
succès
c'est très parlant sur la ville actuelle
fille dans la ville actuelle où il ya
plus d'urbanisme où tout part dans tous
les sens où c'est un dépotoir d'objets
d'objets d'utilitaires parce que les
scooters ça sert à quelque chose
les sculptures ça sert à quelque chose
les lampadaires un dépotoir d'objets et
puis au milieu et bien
du luxe du rêve de la beauté il ya une
deuxième photo là et j'ai mis une
deuxième photo c'est le même reportage à
toute la série comme ça alors là c'est
encore mieux il ya un skate board et à
la voiture il ya le modèle il ya
toujours ce pauvre arbres qui est
protégé et puis à l'ailé cully place que
j'appelle les clips de course puisque
tous ses plus des trous du cul que dès
que des tulipes ccd masturbateur pour
sex-shop toxiques c'est très typique de
la ville actuelle de beaucoup de villes
je dirais pas seulement de paris mais
paris spécialement en ce moment mais
vire c'est très typique et parlera tout
et on est en train de remettre le
monument au milieu de la pelouse qu'on a
dévasté pour le m je pense qu'on mettra
peut-être du barbelé autour pour que les
gens aillent pas le tag et c'est celle
ci on a beaucoup parlé aura plus qu il
s'agit en fait c'est morizio catalan
donc est un artiste contemporain cabourg
expliqué vraiment c'est un baby les gens
croient toujours que ça il faut le
prendre au premier degré non maurizio
cattelan sait jamais au premier degré
c'est lui qui avait fait une très belle
image ou envoyé jean paul ii qui avait
été anéantie par un météorite
c'était aussi pour dire alors il ya un
autre il ya un autre artiste qui a
beaucoup goûté son son son oeuvre
puisqu'il marché de la banane vu une
forme d'art contemporain on peut le cd
vendu assez cher enfin je sens à 1000
euros
voilà ça va mieux et puis un autre
artiste qui est venu qui a mangé là-bas
et quel marché de la banane et je fais
ça à la fois à peu près ce que kafkaïen
et un petit côté un peu absurde sur la
futilité certaines choses peut-être
aussi sur cette société du paraître
finalement puisque là on est dans la
communication est ce qu'on est vraiment
dans l'art là la question de l'art
contemporain est ce que parfois c'est
pas une imposture c'est une vraie
question
mais je pense que c'est la question que
pose boychuk et hélène comme marcel
duchamp posé la même question quand il
n'exposait haredim être très jeune est
ce qu'il faut le prendre au sérieux ou
pas ça c'est le problème des 11000 euros
cet achat
c'est le problème de celui qui paye cent
vingt mille euros c'est clair également
je suis bien d'accord avec vous et je
trouvais ça effectivement trois traits
de troisième degré
alors moi j'ai choisi cette image c'est
une photo que j'ai prise dans une
boutique de balai au japon ça n'est donc
pas une oeuvre de marcel duchamp
non mais ça pourrait être au musée du
quai branly parce qu'il ya un côté
sculpture non je trouvais ça intéressant
parce que bon j'aurai plus de choisir
une image de d'un objet catastrophique
ultra technologique et je pensais que
c'était intéressant de revenir au ballet
c'est très simple et en plus le ban s
intéresse personne s'il n'y a pas eu de
en tout cas en occident il ya eu aucune
innovation technique sur le ballet quoi
quand on cherche un ballet ya qu un
modèle quasiment un truc qui se lisent
comme ça avec les toiles en plastique et
ça intéresse personne s'intéresse moins
que les trottinettes c'est vrai je me
suis dit c'est c'est à pisser ça
correspond je crois que c'est une sorte
de pratiques méditatives de balayer
aussi parce qu'on a c'est dans le
d'existence pour les pour les nuls voilà
donc ces chaussures ont dit que c'est
très bon oui aussi sur votre virement
mais évidemment il ya un impact va
prêter du vocabulaire moderne là ça il
ya un impact écologique forcément de
faire débat les emplois mais sur les
arbres on va voir les mineurs sont beaux
ils sont hyper org
il pourrait pas être en passer par des
applications parce qu'ils seraient ils
ont chacun quelque chose de spécifique
c'est ce qu'on m'avait expliqué et
c'était une boutique entièrement
spécialisé en emballage donc ça
correspond à l'époque spécialisation
l'hyper stylisation voilà alors c'est
une de mes idoles
ah c'est vrai sur un avis et daf et
aline hodja personnage mythique voilà
aucune apologie voilà nasreddine que
personnage mythique de des balkans à la
mongolie et en particulier du côté de la
turquie du côté de l'iran la boukhara
c'était sur la place centrale de
bukharov un voyage que j'ai fait
quelques années l'on se raconte dans
tout le dans tout l'orient et les
discordes entre jake est une sorte de
diogène orientale c'est comme ça qu'on
pourra peut le définir
pourquoi j'ai eu envie de cette image
parce qu'elle dit quelque chose qui je
crois me manque beaucoup à l'époque il
ferait beaucoup de bien c'est à dire
l'irrévérence une forme de rapport à la
légèreté à l'absurdité aussi c'est
quelqu'un qui est capable de se moquer
des puissants de timour langue un peu
comme diogène se moquer d'alexandre le
grand
quelqu'un qui est capable de dire son
fait du coup hop 800 mais en même temps
d'avoir une imagination forcené
d'apporter un grain de folie qui en fait
s'avère être très souvent une source de
sagesse et c'est pour ça que j'ai eu
envie d chez nous pour en savoir plus
sur la zi nord jahia alim qui s'appelle
sublime parole du marché aux puces ces
tracés du 13ème 14ème siècle voilà élu
jusqu'à nos enfants ou c'est une image
c'est fini la rentrée un peu plus les
chairs vbg l'ekiden sorti un nouvel
album et quelques semaines c'est un
shooteur j'aime beaucoup depuis toujours
depuis ses débuts que je suis comme
beaucoup de gens et j'ai vu à la cigale
avec quinze jours c'était un concert
incroyable et non j'aime beaucoup ce
soir mais ce que je trouve je me rends
compte que notre époque un peu sinistre
dont on va parler je mets bien
aujourd'hui mais rarement l'occasion de
rire moi ce que je suis rien c'est peu
je m'en rende compte dans ma vie
quotidienne je le confesse et je compte
ce personnage là c'est de cet artiste là
me fait rire à chaque fois je les écoute
je l'entends pour moi il a une aura de
commencer une carrière de comédien lyon
lorient ça mais il va faire des films
encore cette année beaucoup et mais dès
que je sens que je l'entends dans une
interview à chapet des surprenants il
n'est jamais là où on l'attend il a une
sorte de poésie et de fantaisie que je
trouve extraordinaire et aujourd'hui on
a un peu besoin de ça et lui je trouve
que j'aime j'aime beaucoup et pas grand
chose tant d'années dykstra très beau
alors c'est une image prise de
l'intérieur d'un violoncelle ont
vraiment du talent c'est l'histoire je
suis violence et les voilà c'est par
hasard est à cette image déjà pour moi
elle est intemporelle
parce que c'est un violoncelle ce
violoncelle que vous voyez il aurait pu
être né hier il aurait aussi pu être
construit à 400 ans sur une architecture
absolument géniale qui étaient déjà là
il ya 400 ans avec des luthiers qui
avaient énormément réfléchi donc une
architecture très complexe et ont déjà
bannies des fermions exactement en tout
cas on n'a pas trouvé mieux
essayez donc elle a traversé sept
instruments comme le violon violon dont
nous avons traversé les époques les
révolutions technologiques les liait
les exodes les modes les snobismes tous
à eux et ils sont restés et ils nous ont
survécu et nous survivrons encore
longtemps je crois donc je trouve ça
très réjouissant d'être en contact avec
cet instrument tous les jours qui en
plus est un instrument très fusionnelle
on en sert entre ses jambes contient
contre son coeur et j'aime aussi à
croire que dans cette sorte de grenier
parce que ce que j'aime dans cette photo
c'est qu'elle nous montre pas seulement
un bel outil ni une oeuvre d'art elle
nous montre un lieu c'est là où ça se
passe et ça c'est là où ça se passe
depuis des siècles et je pense aussi à
voilà il ya ba qui à mozart il ya un
schubert qui sont là dedans et
certainement les battements de coeur de
tous les instrumentistes qui ont qui
vont passer jouer cet instrument est qui
et qui continueront à passer donc je me
demande un petit peu où va tout ça et il
ya quelque chose d'assez mystique je
dois dire outre le fait aussi que c'est
un outil bien sûr c'est un outil de
travail
c'est ce qui fait que quand vous prenez
l'avion vous payer double doublé place
mais on peut avoir aussi il ya un
deuxième plat végétarien pour l'une et
sel et un deuxième bouteille de vin mais
s'ils échouent girl mais c'est tout le
monde la voit exactement c'est quand
même tous ces génies ils ont besoin de
manger aussi sont comme nous oui oui je
crois que j'avais envoyé une photo de
trump et kim jong-un pour se faire faire
leurs shampoing côte-à-côte nom ait
alors j'adore cette image j'adore cette
image parce que il ya quelque chose
d'assez surréaliste et j'aime bien
l'idée que le rêve et la réalité sont
pas si séparés et notre monde plein d'
absurdité finalement on se pose la
question de savoir si c'est la réalité
et nos rêves qui sont pas toujours très
fantaisiste on se pose la question de
savoir si c'est vraiment des rêves et
j'aime bien cette image d'un d'un
bricoleur un peu poète qui essayent à sa
manière de nous mettre des étoiles plein
les yeux
hp dit qu'il voulait décrocher la lune
ou alors qu'il essaye de la remettre
[Musique]
m